outside the military headquarters in
Khartoum protesters are making their
voices heard they're fed up with decades
of autocratic rule and they've been
calling for democracy for almost four
months we will only accept a real change
satisfying the revolutionary people who
are looking for a good future the
Sudanese people reject the military
chiefs who ended the thirty-year regime
of the veteran President Omar al-bashir
but the Army is still very much in
charge
Bashir successor áwhat eben oof is a
general link to the genocide in Darfur
and he lasted just one day on the job
before announcing his resignation many
are unhappy that he was replaced by
another army commander though Abdel
Fattah berhan is not wanted for war
crimes rohan immediately sought to
appease the crowds on the streets he
announced the end of a curfew imposed by
his predecessor and promised that a
civilian government would be formed
within two years but the demonstrators
want a clean break from the old regime
we will never leave this place
we will shout it out together we will
shout it out to our freedom or Liberty
do our dark due to the injustice of the
Sudanese we all seeking for for justice
we all seeking for freedom we're seeking
for another new government representing
by out by out by our own people
demonstrators say the first step towards
a new beginning is to replace the
military transition council with the
civilian government joining me in the
studio now to talk about this more is
DWS and thatäôs Aris thanks for joining
us nada
now protesters are insisting on more
rapid change and in particular on a
civilian government why because they
know that there is a very short and very
brief window for a real change they
think if they now hand over the power to
a military council then this military
council could really seize power and
stay in power for the next maybe 30
years that like what happened in
Sudan back 30 years ago when a mother
here himself led a military coup and
then appointed himself president so they
don't want this scenario to repeat
itself they also think we don't want to
see what happened in Egypt in the north
northern neighbor Egypt to repeat itself
in Sudan were military council in a
literary defense chief the Fatah has
c.c. to cover power and then stayed in
power and now he's the president of
Egypt they don't want this in Sudan to
repeat itself okay and yet the new
interim leader yesterday promised to
quote uproot the old regime of President
Bashir so how credible is the promise
that he made yesterday people are very
suspicious they say okay this abdel
fattah Pahang he wasn't from the inner
circle of the former president omar
Bashir but there is no confidence
between the military and the protest
movement now there's still no confidence
they are negotiating there is a
delegation who will continue negotiating
with the Military Council today but what
they basically want is a kind of a
goodwill gesture to see ok this military
council is not gonna reign forever it
will hand over the power to a civilian
that transitional government and they
don't want a military council to can
lead this transition they want a
presidential council with the military
as aside from several sides and not
leading this this in this council so
there is a lack of trust you're saying
and yet the talks between the protesters
and the military council are continuing
who would you say has the upper hand
right now I would say if the protests
continue in the magnitude and the
strength that we have been seeing in the
last week in seven days then the protest
movement has the upper hand
they will say in the streets they will
continue their sit-in in front of the
military headquarters and card woman
also in other countries we also have to
remember that there are many other parts
of Sudan they are taking part in this
uprising so I think there is a kind of
movement and the protesters can you know
step up the pressure and they have I
think the upper hand now
okay so real people's power movement now
DW is not else Aris thank you so much